radio canada prévoit que si la tendance
se maintient le prochain gouvernement
sera formé par le parti libéral louis
plamondon réélu c'est un autre guerre
libéral dé stephen harper ruth ellen
brosseau elisabeth ming qui est
important de comprendre c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une démarche journalistique au
cours de la réunion éditorial qu on
contient quelques jours avant le jour du
scrutin
on donne un code à chaque
circonscription
par exemple dans une circonscription
donnée selon les informations dont on
dispose que ce soit donc des reportages
terrain des informations qui nous
viennent de sondage qui nous viennent
des partis eux mêmes
on va donner un code cette
circonscription là par exemple que c'est
le parti conservateur qui a de bonnes
chances de l'emporter dans cette
circonscription
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice roy bienvenue à cette soirée
électorale au moment de la soirée
lorsque les résultats nous parviennent
sont dans cette circonscription la
l'ordinateur va nous faire une
recommandation d'élire un candidat via
un journaliste qui se trouve derrière
son ordinateur prend connaissance des
recommandations de l'ordinateur du
logiciel en fait il consulte les
résultats au cours de la soirée t il va
se retourner vers un corps d'un à part
un autre journaliste qui va valider avec
lui les informations et donc ces deux
personnes vont prendre la décision de
faire une prévision d'élections
concernant le candidat dans cette
circonscription donnée au canada près la
tendance du vote se maintient que le
prochain gouvernement sera conservateur
et qu'il sera dirigé par steven antin
tout repose sur sur deux personnes deux
journalistes un journaliste de siby
c'est un journaliste de radio canada et
ces gens là doivent suivre la tendance
générale du vote pour déterminer une
prédiction généralement au cours des
dernières années ça se fait dans deux
moments différents on va donc donner la
couleur du gouvernement et on va ensuite
donné on déterminer s'il s'agit d'un
gouvernement minoritaire ou majoritaire
souvent à 20
avant le jour du scrutin il va y avoir
eu des discussions éditorial qu'est ce
qui ferait que ont par exemple on ferait
une prédiction de gouvernement
minoritaire en premier ou en deuxième
dans charest du dandé fait d'un cheikh
vaud jean charest des faits dans
cherbourg d'abord je pense que le
service d'information a reconnu qu'il
avait fait une erreur c'est un fait ce
qui s'est passé en 2007 c'était lié à la
façon dont le directeur de scrutin avait
décidé de comptabiliser le vote par
anticipation les organisateurs libéraux
le disque le parti québécois à contester
systématiquement les boîtes du vote par
anticipation qui se faisait ce qui a
retardé de beaucoup ce vote
et ça c'est un vote de participation qui
est étonnant charest finalement voilà
libéré depuis ce temps là mais c'est
toujours quelque chose dont on comprend
considération on a des discussions avec
avec élections canada mais aussi souvent
avec même et directeur de scrutin parce
qu'elle vote par anticipation sera
comptabilisé au début de la soirée
tout au long de la soirée ou à la fin de
la soirée et en fonction de ces
informations là on note décision va voir
différentes
c'est sûr que toujours un principe de
prudence c'est pas une course à des
normes et pratiques journalistiques on
doit respecter tout au long d'une soirée
électorale qui sont les mêmes qu'on
respecte lorsqu'on fait le travail
domestique à radio canada en général